(film reel spins)
(beeping)
(upbeat hip hop music)
♪ Start of my life was rough ♪
♪ I had an uphill battle ♪
♪ The doctor sat my parents down ♪
♪ And said my life was fragile ♪
♪ Respected in the game
I guaranteed the name ♪
♪ It's what you had
done through the work ♪
♪ And everything would change ♪
♪ Sipping tea help the feels ♪
♪ Yeah that's what I wanted ♪
♪ Being patient hella
tricky if I'm being honest ♪
♪ Tea with Gary Vee ♪
♪ With some positivity yeah ♪
- What's good, what's good, what's good.
Good morning everybody.
Good morning, good morning, July 7th
in the building, big day.
Here we are Team Gary
Vee, glad to be back.
Last week was fire.
Let's see if we can keep
that momentum going.
Let me get some shout outs
to everybody in the comments.
Are we all part of the share squad?
Let's definitely like take the URLs.
Let's hit the share button across
all the platforms let's share.
Share, share, share, share, share,
share, share, share, share.
Keith Jordan what's good.
Lathia, what's good.
Yami Soto, thank you for joining us.
Ted Parmesan, what's good.
Kelly Hill on Facebook,
is in the building.
Jeffrey K, Connor Gray, what's good.
Jake Ward on LinkedIn is in the building.
Voiceover Donny on Periscope,
is in the building.
Hey Dave A on LinkedIn.
Where's the Twitch family?
Where's the Twitch fam,
there's the Twitch family.
Sus to the C, what up?
Willie D in the building,
we love Willie D.
Rohit, great to see you,
Sandy S good to see you.
Elijah Luth in the building.
Morning, morning,
morning, morning, morning.
Dustin, hope you're doing well.
Share, share, share,
share, share, share, share.
Let's get that going, Dustin.
I'm sure you're working behind the scenes.
Maybe that's why you're not popping in.
But oh, there you are.
- You just said hi, so I
was like, okay (laughs).
- Well, you know, I want you in the mix.
- Oh, thank you.
- You are the star of Tea with Gary Vee.
- Nah (laughs)
- Buy any sports cards in the last week?
- Pokemon.
- Let's go.
- I think I paid a little
too much, but (laughs).
- I don't, it won't, you
won't end up paying too much.
That market is fine.
- Yeah I know, I've been doing research
and I was like, damn, only two months ago,
it was like half the price it is now.
I'm like fuck!
(laughing)
- Everything in sports
cards, every basketball,
soccer and Pokemon and wrestling card,
was at half the price, two months ago.
It's just crazy how hot it is.
- Yeah.
- All right, let's get in the show.
- Cool.
- Yo yo Gary Dee, what's good, man.
- What's good Jaycee, how are you?
- Great man, good morning,
good morning, good morning.
- Good morning, well, I can.
- Awesome, awesome.
So I just want to say thank you
for everything, honestly,
I've been watching
your show for years at this point.
I don't know if you remember me,
but we have met at ComplexCon LA.
- I recall.
- Yeah, I was waiting in line.
They were like, you got to buy the shoes.
And I was like, I didn't
come to buy a shoe.
I came to talk to Gary,
I know he'll talk to me.
So, appreciate that for sure.
So I just want to tell you a little bit
about myself, a little bit
of context of what I do.
I told you my company
before is Joke's LLC,
basically our mission is to inspire
and instill confidence
in those who have been
laughed at misunderstood, overlooked
by the hands of normality, through design,
art and fashion.
So how I got to the name Joke's?
So I was a dancer for
eight years, hip hop dance.
Main inspiration, kinda
did that for a while.
Went to college, Temple University,
joined a dance team.
My goal was to open up a nonprofit
dance organization for kids
and I blew out my knee.
So this is the third
time I blew out my knee.
And I was just like, dance has always been
something freeing for me, you know?
And then it became something of fear.
You know, I was like, every time I dance,
I'm going to, I'm going to bust my knee.
- Yeah, of course.
- Yup, so I had to find something to focus
my creativity you know,
and I started painting.
So I've always been like artistic.
And I took that painting
and the name Joke's
comes from my dance name.
So my dance name was Joke Star.
And I took that when I was like 16
and started to brand it.
So I turned Joke Star into a noun.
So what that meant was an individual,
who despite being
criticized, or made fun of,
who sticks to their goals
and eventually shines.
- Got it.
- So my view was I was going to turn kids
from jokes to stars by
teaching them confidence
through dance, because
that's what it gave me.
- I love that.
- Thank you, thank you, I appreciate it.
And that whole entire thing switched
when I stopped dancing.
So I kind of lost myself, lost the mission
and I found painting and at the time
I was calling my paintings Joke's Art,
I was just doing it because it was already
my branding name.
And then what had happened was,
I started putting my paintings on t-shirts
and then it clicked and it
was literally Joke's on me.
And I was like, wow.
And then it was like Joke's on us.
So when you wear it, it's Joke's on you,
when I wear it, it's Joke's on me,
when we were at Joke's on us.
So I took my name, I
got the LLC, Joke's LLC
and I was like, alright,
I got a fashion brand now
with the Joke's on us.
And I'm still doing the art
with Joke's Art G`allery.
So it's kind of like the
parent company's Joke's.
- It's just a whole lot of fucking Joke's.
- A whole lot of Joke's, because
at the end of the day, what I'm trying
to do is let everybody
know, that ultimately
the Joke's on us, you know,
it's a confidence thing.
Everybody gets made fun of, everybody
gets pushed around.
- Of course.
- What are you going to do about it?
What are you gonna do about it you know.
So when you wear this,
when you wear this brand,
when you see the Joke's,
when you see the name,
I basically want that to mean confidence.
You know, I want it to be where
if someone's wearing Gucci or someone's
wearing EZZE, it's like it doesn't matter
what they're wearing, you know?
Cause the Joke's on us.
Like it's all over us,
they can be wearing--
- You've completely established it.
I got it, go ahead, so.
- Thank you, thank you.
Awesome.
- So, what can I answer?
- So basically, my goal is,
I'm trying to get Joke's on the world.
And I'm not really, I feel like,
being a true artist, it's hard for me
to conform to the social media,
the Instagram, the white
boxes, the posting.
And I feel like, I'm trying to create art
to fit in these boxes, you know
and it's not working out for me very well.
- Well and so you're trying to figure out
how to translate the
mission and the message
and the content onto social?
- Well, that's part of it, I think
I'm doing pretty good at
getting the message out,
but I think the trouble I have,
is just focusing on the social.
You know, I kind of want to just go in
all in on the art and to give a little bit
more context, like I was a business major
in college I worked for insurance.
So I have a day job in insurance,
I do all of this on that backend,
but it's hard for me
to balance the business
and the art, you know?
So I kind of like, I'm
having troubles with that.
And I kind of just want to go full fledged
with the art, but I have this job.
I have student loan debt
and all that stuff, so.
- Well, I mean, there's
a lot of variables here.
One, no different than if I was a dancer,
that'd be a big fucking disaster.
Are you actually capable
of building a business,
is number one.
- Okay.
- Are you, something that you have
to figure out too, you're
in the practical part
of your life right now,
unfortunately you have
these student loans, so you've got to have
this job, you know, there's
couple ways to play it.
One, you go all in on
the art and business,
potentially even with a business partner,
who might be better at business than you.
And do that for a year,
give yourself a year,
give yourself two years.
And if it doesn't work out, then you go,
you keep collecting interest on that debt
and then you go back to practicality,
but you always felt like you went for it,
or do you go the other route and kind of
eat some more shit for
another three, four years?
Do that on the side.
I think the biggest thing
that stands out for me,
is are you actually getting, you know,
it's fun that you're such a talent
in art and dance because it, because
you then recognize that
other people can't--
You know, how you and your boys and girls
made fun of other people
for not being able
to dance you know, that's kind of how
I do it with business.
Like, you know, like, you know, you just,
and when I say make fun of it,
you're not doing Joke's.
You are recognizing, oh
shit, this is talent.
And I think Jaycee, the
biggest thing you need
to figure out is are you actually capable?
Are you actually capable
of running a business,
that's going to have people buy art,
buy clothes, do things.
And the reality is
oftentimes, even on this show,
we can be around the bush, kind of
skirting the issue,
which is a lot of people
just don't know how to build businesses.
- So to give a little context
in my business history.
So I started a lawn, I
started a landscaping business
when I was 13, me and
my homie, we went around
all did all that stuff, I worked at Subway
when I was 16 and then after that,
I was like a janitor at a school.
- You have work ethic.
- Yeah.
- Like nobody fucking tries harder
than me playing basketball.
- Right.
- The problem is I couldn't play
on a high school basketball team,
let alone a professional one.
I think it's very clear to me,
I could even see in your conviction
and then even your rebuttal here,
that I think you have the work ethic.
The question is, do you have the talent
to sell enough paintings and hoodies
and tee shirts to make
that a sustainable living?
That is something you have
to really ask yourself.
And if the answer is no, if you're being
really raw, then you go
and get a business partner.
If the answer's yes, then
you make the decision
of one of two moves.
You jump out of insurance and you go
full throttle for 24 months on this.
Get really fucking raw,
eat, eat, you know,
spend money on nothing, but like food
and shelter, collect even more debt,
because you're compounding your interests.
You're not doing payments because
you're going all in on the art thing.
And you go two years on that.
And then if it doesn't work, you go back
and you feel great that you tried,
or you go the other route next two years,
you fucking save every dollar.
Don't spend anything, start paying off
that debt and then jump full throttle
in two or three years or four years
and go for it, that's just the decision
you have to make for yourself.
- Gotcha.
I think where I'm at right now is,
so the business has
been doing pretty well.
I have products worldwide, I
just got orders in Denmark.
- How much, how much tell, the truth here?
How much top line revenue for the year
is the business doing?
- So--
- Sales for the year.
- Sales for the year, I'd have to like,
double look into that, but--
- Roughly.
- Been at LSE for three
years, I've been doing
the online business for three years.
First year we did about
a grand, very minimal,
you know, just friends and family.
Second year, it was like a 3,500
and this year we just broke 10 K.
So it's grown--
- That's in sales.
And then with profit, it's
going to be much slower.
All of which is not
sustainable for you to live on.
And I think, I think, again,
I think the question is,
it's a three pronged attack for you.
Do you need a business partner?
- Yup.
- Who's really got it.
She or he in business and if not
and you feel like you're doing 10 K,
because you have so little time on it.
But if you go full
throttle, you can get it
to a 100 K, then you gotta decide,
are you going to do that
now and get deeper in debt,
or are you going to do
that in three years,
after you got yourself out a little bit.
That's it, that's the answer Jaycee.
- Yeah and I think with what I'm doing
right now is like, it is a fear of scale
a little bit, because I'm
doing, so I'm printing
all the stuff myself, you know,
I'm doing all the printing myself.
I also do like designing and hand painting
on clothing pieces for musical artists.
Like I got a pair of pants, Steve Aoki,
so the goal really is, is to kind of
get into that sphere of music and hip hop
with like custom pieces
that are higher end.
- I get it, I get it.
- And then it kind of like
pushed the brand that way.
- Yep, yes, I understand.
(laughs)
You gotta, you gotta figure out
the three things I told you.
Do you need a partner that can really
drive the business, or
if you don't because
you have a lot of pride and belief
in your business savviness,
which are showing in this call,
you need to then jump
now, go full throttle
for 24 months and always felt like
you went for it, or
save every fucking penny
you can pay off debt, go raw.
Don't buy any fucking stupid shit
for 24 months and then jump and do it.
That's your three options.
- Okay, okay.
- Alright, bro, you got it.
- One more thing.
- Real quick,
real quick.
- I'm trying to get Joke's on the world.
Can we give a shout out to the Instagram?
- Yeah, it's right here.
It's been up the whole time.
There you go, everybody follow it.
Thanks Jaycee, talk to
you, let's keep it moving.
Yu-Gi-Oh getting a lot
of love in the comments.
Yeah, I mean I think, oh, there he is.
- S'up bro.
- There they are.
Mr. Genske good to see you, AJV.
- Hey yo.
- Great to see you in the building,
Greg, you hear me?
- Good morning guys, good morning.
- Good morning, all right, like I told
a bunch of you on social media,
we have a fairly big
announcement this morning.
It's been a fun month for me, obviously
last week, the announcement of the sale
of Empathy Wines was a big deal.
And today, we are announcing, with this
handsome young man you see on the screen,
Greg Genske I think all of you know
AJ Vaynerchuk, my
delightful younger brother,
we're announcing the
expansion of VaynerSports.
We've been in football for what is it,
five years now AJ?
- Four and change.
- Four and a half years on football.
So I'll let you AJ and Greg,
kind of take over the announcement
and well, I'm pretty excited about it.
Now, as soon as you hear the announcement,
please share on social, get the word out,
go ahead, AJ and Greg.
- Cool. I'll give it the simple line.
And then Greg, I'll let you expand.
Like Gary said, we've been football
for the last four and a half years
and this marks the
moment in which we expand
into baseball, so we're fired up.
Greg is going to lead the charge
and I'll let him go into detail.
- And Greg, give a little
bit of a background
of your career, we've
partnered up with Greg
and creating VaynerBaseball
and VaynerSports.
Greg, a little context on you?
- Yeah, I'm you know, a sports aficionado
my entire life, I was a baseball player,
wanted to do that, that didn't work out,
became a trial lawyer, loved trying cases,
but I was brought into
the sports agent world
almost 20 years ago.
And so for 20 years, I've been dedicated
at representing professional athletes
and really loving it, loving it,
had had a lot of success,
had the privilege
of working for some really,
really great athletes,
working with some really great partners,
learning a lot and in
starting this new agency,
it was really the focus for me,
to find the absolute
best partners available,
both on the client side
and with the company.
And I just got to tell you guys,
I'm ecstatic that we're
able to come together
and really enhance this offering.
And I'm able to take my
20 years of perspective,
looking at this business and determining
what would be the absolute best model
to provide the best
representation to players
and what you guys have
done on the business side,
in the sports side, coupled with what
I think myself and my very talented staff
bring to the table is really unprecedented
in the industry.
We're going to be able to do some really
dynamic things for athletes.
And I couldn't be more excited.
- AJ, thoughts from your perspective?
- Yeah, I mean, Greg hit it on the head.
I think that we spent these last few years
proving out a different model.
I think VaynerSports
and I think what really
linked us all together, has really
driven home the idea that we don't just
represent athletes, but
we represent human beings
and athletes today versus athletes,
even maybe when Greg started his career,
have much more of a
focus on, off the field
and what they're able
to do with the platform
that the NFL or major league
baseball provides them.
And so I think our success
and our unique background
in terms of entrepreneurship, investing,
you know, Gary, what you've done
with your personal brand,
that has a lot of guys
gravitating towards what we can offer.
And I think the other
piece of it too, Greg,
I want you to go into more detail.
You're being humble, you know,
some of the work that you've done
and some of these
contracts that you've done,
they're legit-legit.
And so, you know, maybe just kinda
highlight a few of them.
- Yeah. Greg, if I'm
reading your Wikipedia
properly, 4 billion in
contracts that, you know,
now that's pretty fucking serious shit.
- Yeah, we were very busy as an agency.
We were very fortunate to have a lot of
really good clients and I say that,
it was a privilege.
And one thing I'm very confident about,
is that myself and my staff, Joe Mizzo,
Eric Izen and the other
agents that work with me,
Vernon Wells, now that he's an agent,
is every time--
- By the way,
quick fun facts on Vernon Wells,
Vernon Wells was the backbone of two
fantasy championships
for my brother, AJ here.
I hated Vernon Wells, 'cause AJ had him
at a cheap price in our
fantasy baseball game.
- First thing I told Vernon,
when Greg connected us,
was like, hey man, you sent me two rings.
That was big, I appreciate it.
(laughing)
And Greg, Vernon was one of
your record-setting deals
when he was your client, right?
- Yeah, correct, so we've had the,
like I said, we've had the privilege
of representing a lot of great players
at the important stage of their career
and we we've always delivered
on the contract side.
And Vernon Wells certainly
is one of those players
with a record setting, $126 million deal,
a revolutionary player
opt-out at that time,
which we then duplicated
in the Sabathia deal
and a few other deals.
So we've always been
extraordinarily focused,
as we should, on maximizing
client compensation,
setting new records,
not just for our clients
but fore the industry as a whole,
so that the industry can grow
and we can continue to represent
players' rights and
maximize the competition.
And Vernon has added it
to his Wikipedia page,
that he's one of the stars of you guys
fantasy baseball teams.
(laughing)
- You know, from my perspective,
you know, AJ and I, this is fun,
because we went into football one way,
we got a very small
shop, we wanted to learn.
We didn't know much about
the sports representation
business, AJ had a real passion,
decided to leave VaynerMedia,
wanted to get into that world.
That was a really fun execution.
And we learned the pros and
cons of going that route.
And now we're kind of going the other way.
I mean, Greg is keeping it wildly humble,
but we have incredible ambition
for our VaynerBaseball practice.
One, we think baseball players are grossly
underrepresented off
the field in speaking,
in books, in products and services,
merchandise, and definitely
social media endorsement.
And definitely investing,
AJ helped one of our
VaynerSports football
players, Derick Morgan,
the great star from the Tennessee Titans,
made a very smart transition from instead
of taking a brand deal, converting that
into equity and the company went public,
bringing that kind of savviness
to these baseball players who don't have
the level of access
that I think NBA players
and other celebrities have,
to get into Angel rounds.
You know, I obviously
had a great, incredible,
investing career, but so did AJ,
as we were navigating that.
And he got into a lot of things early
and smartly and so that's number one,
number two, you know, all of them all,
all baseball players are way less famous
than they should be,
you know, when I think
about the general population of baseball,
of America, excuse me, the demographics,
this country has an incredible influx
of Latin, Spanish speaking Americans.
And when you think about
the best, you know,
South American, Central
America, Mexico, DR,
Latin, Spanish-Americans playing sports,
it's all baseball.
And when you look at
Vlad and Tatis and Soto
and Baez, the stars, Lindor, the stars
of baseball are Spanish
speaking baseball players,
in a country that is
emerging Spanish speaking
at such a level.
And yet there's so, so
much left on the table.
And I believe much like
we looked at football,
I would argue baseball
even more than football,
is falling short on
off-the-field opportunities
for generational wealth creation,
outside of remarkably large contracts,
that baseball players get to enjoy.
I think, you know, I would,
to me that excites me
to no end and I think that's, you know,
what's really cool Greg,
is that we basically
are now, with this announcement, in play
for every baseball player on earth,
because what you've been able to do,
in your incredible career, enables
every single baseball
player to feel confident
that they can get the contract done,
that they need to get
done, with you at the helm.
And then, you know, I mean,
I've watched everything
from A-Rod, G Bird, to
every single, you know,
to Harper to Trout, you
know, there is no better
entity for off-the-field marketing
and business execution as of this second,
than VaynerBaseball and baseball.
And that includes the
top two or three firms
that have been around in
the sport in perpetuity.
And so that, that excites me.
I think we're going to
make substantial noise
and football was a marathon for AJ And I,
you know, we knew it was
kind of a 10 year play,
but I do think baseball is going to happen
a little bit quicker with this combo.
- I think you're absolutely right, Gary.
It's going to happen very quickly.
The baseball, the
professional baseball market's
been very underserved
when it comes to the type
of offering that Vayner brings.
When it comes to
educating them on becoming
business persons, becoming entrepreneurs,
to think that way, to market themselves,
to create a brand and that's what
has attracted me to
come join VaynerSports,
more than anything, is to really be honest
and be true about being able to affect
great change and great things for each
individual athlete that we represent.
And knowing that we have
that core capability
in-house, is unbelievable because after
doing this for 20 years, my only ambition
is to do the absolute best job to provide
the absolute best services.
And what I love about
you guys, is you're right
on the same page with me.
I'm really good at my job and I do
a really good job, but
a fundamental aspect
of it, is educating each client
that I'm working with,
so that they develop
as men or women in some cases and get to
a point of running their own business.
They know how to do it.
And what we offer as
opposed to other agencies,
that maybe do a great job
for some superstar clients,
is we are going to bring that capability
to every client that we represent.
- Yeah, I think another
aspect too, you know,
in addition to the three people talking
through it right now, Mike Neligan,
our EVP of marketing and sales.
The one who actually
connected the three of us,
I think you layer on the innovation,
the multifaceted approach
that Gary and I have,
the disruption, Greg, you and your team's
track record of doing great work on the
business side and then Mike having
an extensive history, 15 years or so,
of the traditional and untraditional
endorsements, sales, marketing solutions.
I think you just take those three things,
you just create this
cocktail that's perfect.
- Absolutely right, I've been a big fan
of Mike Neligan's work for a long time.
We've talked for a long time, about how
we can work together and now bringing
us all together--
- Here we are.
- Is a dream--
- Here we are, all alright,
I'm going to get back to my show.
Big announcement, I'm really
excited about it boys.
Ready to get to work.
- So thank you--
- Looking to convert
some of my fantasy players
on my team to actual
VaynerSports play.
And now I'm gonna buy a lot
more baseball rookie cards.
So I'm excited about that part as well.
Greg, welcome to the family.
AJ, I'm really excited about
this next chapter for us.
- Love you bro.
- Love you.
- Thanks guys, see ya.
- Bye everyone, take care, bye.
VaynerBaseball in the building,
VaynerSports.com.
If you've got a nephew that's crushing
baseball and we're
really excited about it.
All right, I think, I think we can
move on with the show.
- Yo.
- What's up Jack?
- What up Gary?
- How are you?
- And I knew I knew you're dressed man,
so I had to pull out my--
- Dan Marino? (laugh)
- My Dan the Man shirt.
- But you're too young to be
You didn't even get to
see him play, did you?
- Na, I didn't get to see him play,
but I heard all about him, so.
- He was a beast, I hate
him, but he was a beast.
- Right, gotcha.
(coughs) I'm in Eugene, Oregon.
I think you asked that.
- What's that brother?
- I'm in Eugene, Oregon.
I think you asked before.
- I love that, I love that.
Yep, I did, what's cooking.
- By the way, I just wanted to talk first
about this, I know you talk a lot about
the Craigslist stuff and I've been on that
forever man, like seriously, every morning
I go to that Craigslist free section.
That's probably made
like seven grand selling,
like ellipticals,
treadmills, bench presses.
Like just the stuff that people
put for free, it's insane.
- You know, I, when I started talking
about that two, three years ago and I was,
it was something I told friends to do,
for the last 20 years,
like when you have nothing,
when you have a little
and you're willing to work
and you have hard work ethic in you,
the ability to like,
if you're lucky enough
to have a truck to pick up heavy things
that people want for free, it's yeah.
I see it bro, that's game over.
I mean, you know, that's
incredible, good for you.
What can I answer for you?
- Guaranteed man, I've seen like,
I got like the shaker machine for free.
I sold it for like 600 bucks last week.
It's like, it's insane, the kind of stuff
you'll see on Craigslist.
- I love it, what can
I answer for you, bro?
- Yeah, so I've been going
to college right now.
I'm going to U of O, studying business.
Cause I'm always, I've always kinda
been interested in business,
but I just feel like,
like the whole education system,
like it's just kind of
bad, like, you know,
we learned about billboard advertising,
we learned about all sorts of things
that are super outdated and it's just like
something that just
doesn't make sense to me.
Plus like, you know, they're taking school
online now and to where
its not going to go
down a dime and then, so it just really
makes sense to me, like to stay in school.
And I've always like,
you know, had aspirations
to like start a business or do something
like that, but it's hard to get, like,
other people on board
and seeing your vision
because, you know, I tell my family like,
you know, I don't want
to really go to college
right now and they're all kinda like,
Oh, you know, you're lazy,
like you're too young.
Like you're not going to be able to do it.
Like, you know, what do
you say to the people
that kind of just like
they want the best for you.
- I don't say anything.
I don't say anything, let me rephrase,
I say, I love you and I know that you want
the best for me, but I gotta live my life
and I'm going to show you.
- Yeah, just get to work.
- Just get to work. Like I
don't, I don't have any interest
in convincing people what I'm up to.
People think, my whole life people thought
I was doing things wrong.
My whole life.
- Yeah.
- There was people, that we just announced
VaynerBaseball and people were like,
ah, that's not gonna work.
You know, like my whole
life, that's what people,
I don't care about talking to people.
I care about showing people.
You know, bunch of my friends,
literally when I launched Empathy Wines.
When I, launched Empathy Wines,
all, a lot of my friends were like,
you're stretching yourself too thin.
You got too much going on.
You can't juggle all this.
And then boom, 18 months later, you know,
selling a company for
half the eight figures.
Like I'm not, I'm not
worried about what people
are saying, I'm worried
about what I'm doing.
- Yeah, no, it's true,
it's just, it's hard
at times with people
like, you know, feeling
the whole thing about --
- It's, it's, it's, it's,
its, it's not hard, it's, let me explain.
Of course it's hard, but then you just,
it's like turning a light switch.
You gotta understand
your parents, your uncle,
your older brother,
your sister, your aunt,
your teacher, your coach,
you gotta understand.
They're giving you advice
that they think is right.
They're not mean, they're not bad.
They love you, they're
trying to show you love.
The problem is, they're coming from
their perspective and their perspective
has nothing to do with your life.
Period.
- And there's the hardcore.
Is like people like, I feel like everybody
just wants the safe option and like,
people want, it's like, know your,
like 10 year plan.
And they're always asking me like,
oh, what's your 10 year plan.
And I'm like--
- Fuck a 10 year plan.
Everyone's 10 year plan
got completely fucked
in March, it was called Corona.
- Yeah facts.
- Fuck, 10 year plans,
there's no, that's stupid.
And I hate that word,
but like, that's silly.
10 years!
That's crazy to me.
Bro, live your life.
(laughs)
Stick it to them.
(connection failing)
- Dustin, it's choppy now, let's move on.
But Jack, thank you so much, bro.
Jack's got it, Jack you
gotta figure it out, bro.
Just live your life.
Listen, here's the punchline.
Somebody is going to be right.
If you think you're so
great and you can go do it
without college, go do it and if you fail,
maybe they were right but maybe also
you would have went to
college and just got
into debt and wasted your time too.
And you would have two losses
and now you've got to go on your third one
and your third idea and guess what?
Doing the business that
failed for five years,
taught you a lot more than
sitting in a classroom.
Learning about things that
happened 10 years ago.
Let's move it.
Tomin.
- Tomin you're on mute.
- There we go.
- What's up?
What's good Tomin?
- Yeah so like--
- How old are you and where are you from?
- I'm 14, I'm from Houston.
- Love it, what's good?
- So like two months ago, I started
a digital media marketing agency.
I was just wondering,
what are your strategies
to get like your first client?
Cause I send like 200
emails, not a single reply.
- In the title put, I will do social media
for you for free.
- Okay.
Okay also one more question.
- Well Tomin, let's sit
on this for a second.
I know you're a smart kid, but like,
you do understand that when you're at
14 years old and you've got something new
and you get zero replies of 200 requests,
the number one move is to get credibility.
So doing that work for free,
for two or three people,
for a month, let's the next email,
in six months say, hi
blank, I did, or I do
the social media for x, y and z,
I'd love to talk to you
about your social media.
Boom, you've got a totally
different conversation.
- All right, I have one more question.
- Please.
- What are your thoughts on drop shipping?
- I'm a fan.
- Okay.
- I think over time, you know, what I love
about drop shipping is, you can learn
the arbitrage of supply and demand
and making margin on
something that you can buy,
that somebody else wants to pay more for,
use the infrastructure of
Amazon to do that for you.
It's a very tech, it's
a very hardcore game.
It's not as easy as it sounds,
but it's an incredible learning process.
It's the same reason I like sports cards.
It's the same reason
I like garage sailing.
Same reason I like Jack
going finding things
on Craigslist for free
and then selling them.
Anything that teaches
you how to buy something
and then resell it for
more is always going
to be a skill that will
stick with you forever.
- All right, thank you,
also one last question.
Can I get a follow?
- You can brother,
- Yes!
- Where's your account?
Lets see here, you can.
Tomin, did you really
grasp the free thing?
Cause you went quick on it.
I just, you know, I want
to make sure you realize
how big of a deal that is.
- All right.
- It's alright brother,
I am your 431st follower.
- Thank you.
- Oh you're taking some pretty photos.
What do you like, you like the sky?
- No, I just went on vacation to Canada
like a year ago.
- Good man, you need more content bro.
Keep your game up.
- Thank you.
- All right, you're welcome, see ya.
Let's keep it going.
Let's keep this going.
(shrieks)
- Hi.
- Hi, I'm so excited to be here.
- I'm happy to have you here.
- First of all, congratulations.
Sorry, my dog is flipping out here.
I gotta--
- I love a dog
no worries from here.
- Gotta get more treats.
(laughing)
- No worries.
- Congratulations on VaynerSports
and all the awesome things you're doing.
- Thank you.
- Thank you for providing
this forum because it's awesome.
And I'm so blown away
to be in the presence
of so many young awesome people,
that if you are a young person,
now this is the time, I
can't stress that enough,
where everything is in your favor
to do whatever you could possibly want.
- Good news, if you're
67 this is the time,
it's called the internet
is at its maturity.
The cost of entry is extremely low
and if you're educated and willing
to put in the work, an
extraordinary amount
of opportunity sits in one's hand,
whether you're 14, 41 or 91.
- Well, that's really encouraging.
I feel like a baby, in
my mind I'm still 27.
Although I've got my 54th coming up here
in a couple of weeks.
- Happy birthday, you look amazing.
(laughing)
- Thanks, lighting, lighting.
- Something that I'd never figured out.
Everyone's like you look horrible.
I'm like, I don't give a fuck about that.
- Just light it up, light it up.
- I know, go ahead.
- And makeup and makeup.
So here's the deal, I have been, you know,
a child and family
therapist for over 30 years,
more than your folks
today have been breathing
probably, but loved doing that.
I focused on child welfare,
early childhood issues,
social emotional issues, autism ADHD,
like the whole gamut, mostly with young,
you know, young kids and parents.
And so I ended up
writing a parenting book.
This is back in 2000, 1999, 2000.
The internet, so that's why I'm so excited
about today because things are there.
Back when I was doing this, I sold out
of three printings of my book.
I self published, all on my own,
just from doing talks and
selling back of the room.
And I was doing all kinds of radio,
but there was no way to deliver the book.
I mean, people would call, you know,
I was trying to get the
website thing going,
it was $10,000 back then to get
a order form.
- I remember.
- So I felt like I'm always
in the wrong timeframe.
And now finally the time is there.
So I was doing really well, I ended up
doing nothing but my public speaking,
signature talks seminars and I burnt out
on the therapies.
So I got into of course,
real estate, which I love,
just investing and also
selling for other folks.
And everything was like going top speed.
And then I got into a five-car pileup
car accident.
- I'm so sorry.
- Which led to finding out about
an ovarian tumor that I had.
And then just to really top it off,
I got into a really crappy marriage.
So all those three
things, it reminded me--
- But Maria, Maria, it sounds like,
if I heard it right,
that the car accident,
it was a blessing because you were able
to get diagnosed earlier
of something that was--
- Oh absolutely.
Yeah, I had zero symptoms and even
the ultrasound didn't find it.
It was only because of the MRI
I needed to have from
the accident for my back.
Otherwise even if I had symptoms,
I'd be dead right now, they would not
have detected it, so
very grateful for that.
And anyway, so the
turnaround, I think it's kind
of like for me, what
happened was, you know,
what's that saying, like
everybody has a plan until
you get punched in the face.
- Mike Tyson.
- And boy, that felt
like a punch in the face.
And it took me a long time, I started
like really questioning,
like, what am I doing?
Maybe I don't know what I'm doing.
You know, all of this stuff.
So I started getting
coaching and that led me
down this rabbit hole of different people
telling me what I should do.
Don't do the parenting
thing, there's no money
in that, do this, go corporate, be this.
And I felt like I really lost my identity
in all of that, so my one issue is just
overload of opinions and input from
all over the place.
Do this funnel, now change
the name of your stuff.
It's too negative.
- It's all that whole world
of internet marketers,
funnels, conversion, transactional.
It's very short term, it's
money over everything.
It's, I understand it's
a world that I think
has a lot of shortcomings.
- Yeah, so it feels
really inauthentic to me.
And so I'm like, all right, I don't want
to be that cheesy, you know?
Oh any buy my program
or, you know, whatever.
But I do have a wealth of knowledge.
I am, you know, the real deal.
I can honestly tell you when it comes
to kids stuff, nobody--
- So, are we talking about
how do we think about a business model?
- Yeah.
Yeah, so, I mean, that has been it,
it's like really focusing the messaging,
or should I not?
- What are you trying to sell?
- I'm not trying to
sell anything right now.
- But what will you try to sell?
Because I think the
strategy has to be based
like for example, do you wanna do
one-on-one therapy and consulting,
or strategy sessions?
And for example, if one wants to do that,
you know, I mean, every day of my life,
I get an email or DM where
people are offering me
levels of money for
just an hour of my time.
That blows my mind.
That's because I took the route
of giving unlimited good content for free,
for a decade for free,
which became the way
that I could have people wanting to pay
me $25,000 for an hour consulting.
I don't wanna do that, I
don't do that, so that's that.
Other people want to do a hundred people
in a group and charge them
a hundred dollars a month.
Other people don't want
to charge anything.
They just want to do
speaking and selling books
because they, like there's a million
different ways to do something.
The question becomes
which one do you want?
What do you feel most authentic about,
is the real question.
- For me, it's the speaking.
And, and even taking it online,
doing online seminars, doing things live.
Having that interaction.
- Then,
you need to put out
unlimited content for free,
across the 10 platforms that matter,
Facebook, Instagram, you know, LinkedIn.
Twitch, TikTok, Podcast, YouTube,
you know, on and on and on.
And you need to do it at the highest level
every day so that you build up demand,
social stuff comes to you.
- Okay, gotcha.
- Maria, whoever is asking
has given up the leverage.
- Okay.
- Let me explain that.
- Yeah.
- If you're putting
out incredible content,
every day, every day,
then people are going
to come to you.
- Gotcha.
- If you're out there trying to figure out
how to like, not bring a whole, like try.
If you're out there trying to figure out
how do you get to a place where you
are getting paid to speak,
then a lot of times, you end up being
the person asking.
Hey, can I speak at your conference?
Hey, you know, how do I get in there at,
you're asking me, hey,
can you introduce me
to the people that you were speaking,
You're asking.
- Right.
- My strategy has been, if I put out
the best information in the world for free
in perpetuity, things will come to me.
And that's how it's worked.
- I get it, I just,
because of my confusion,
I stopped posting, you
know, I have things.
- Good news Maria, you're unconfused now.
Good news, we're confused.
- Yes!
- Unconfused.
- Absolutely.
- You know, if you listen
to somebody who said,
you know, no, you can't
put it out for free,
then nobody's going to pay you for it.
Good news, unconfused, I
do not agree with that.
- Yeah, love it.
- By the way, I could
be wrong, but I can tell
you right now, if you're the real deal,
then you need to be
putting it out for free
and let it come to you.
The more, the real deal you are,
the more that needs to be the strategy.
- Okay, yeah I did a thing of lives.
Like the 12 days of Cray-Cray, before all
this COVID stuff, counting
down to Christmas.
And I got like a really
awesome response to that.
And then I was told, well, you're going
in a different direction, right,
so I think it's needs to be all noises off
and just do my thing.
- I don't like, everything
I've heard from you,
whoever this business coach is,
that you're paying, that's giving you
dog shit advice, we need
to be done with that.
- Okay, just do the do.
- Just do the do.
- Boo, okay.
- Boo.
(laughing)
Listen to me.
- Yes.
- Karma.
Doing the right thing.
Like truly, truly wanting to help,
is always the best business strategy.
- I love that and that's where I was.
That's where I had started.
And then it got all convoluted.
Like I say afterwards,
cause I started out--
- I get it, I get it, I get it.
You got into a mucky spot,
you started doubting.
All of a sudden short
term wins were needed.
Maybe money was needed,
it all makes sense to me.
I respect the shit out
of how you got there.
Good news, we're still young as fuck.
Don't let that fucking 14
year old throw you off.
You know what I mean?
- I love that 14 year old.
- I love Tomin too.
- I wanna hire the 14 year old.
- I love Tomin too, but don't let that age
throw you off, you still have literally
minimally 30 years of real execution
in front of you, maybe at 84, I'm okay
with you going and chillin'.
And so 30 years, 30 years you have a long
fucking future in front of you.
Start doing what comes natural to you.
The other stuff didn't
come natural to you,
which is why it didn't work.
- Exactly.
And I thought yeah, it's
not working, but yeah.
I'm hooking up with
Tomin and I will pay you.
(laughing)
- All right, Tomin, there you go.
- Yeah.
- All right, talk to you.
- Awesome, thank you so much.
(blows kiss)
- Make sure you clarify
hooking up with Tomin.
That's a different kind
of term in today's days.
(laughing)
I'm kidding, like that Dustin?
I got you with that one.
- I thought the same thing.
(laughing)
- We're just idiots.
All right, let's keep on going.
(excitedly exhales)
Jon Z, what's good?
- What's up Gary, how are you?
- I'm well and you?
- I'm doing so well.
So basically I'll get
straight to the point.
For a lot of years, I
wasn't that great at school.
In middle school, I was in a decelerated
learning program and in
high school and college,
I kind of stuck it to my parents.
And I worked really, really
hard, I buckled down,
I've gone straight A's all throughout.
I've taken so many classes that,
I'm 19 right now, I'm
actually going to graduate
in the spring just because I've taken on
such a workload.
And throughout that process.
- Why'd you do that, go ahead,
throughout that process.
- Well, throughout that
process, I was really
set on being a doctor
and I was really excited
about it and it was because I kind of
had an interest in
psychology and was talking
to my parents one day, they're like,
oh, you should be a doctor
and be a psychiatrist,
because that'll make more money.
And so like once that seed was planted,
it kind of grew into a force.
I was like, oh I'll go to med school.
And after freshman year, I was like,
I don't want to do that anymore.
- That's good.
- And I have stuck with my psych major,
but I've been less and less sure about it
as I've gone through college.
And with all of Corona happening
and class and being online,
I was thinking about
taking a semester off,
starting a business and maybe even trying
to drop out or, but what my college did,
is they shortened the requirement
for how many semesters you have to stay.
A lot colleges, you actually just stay
eight semesters, like you're not allowed
to graduate early.
My college let us, so I'm just gonna
finish my degree and I started a business
this summer and I'm
kinda having a hard time
getting away from, oh
I got A's this quarter,
or A's this semester, like, that's great,
I did a good job, I can see it,
to something more intangible.
Like how should I judge myself?
And where should I set that bar?
- I love this question.
I think you should judge yourself based on
how happy you are on a daily basis.
- Okay.
- Stick with me here.
- Yeah.
- The number one thing I don't like
about school is the
short term gratification
of a tangible, subjective often, result
that reinforces stay-in-the-lane behavior.
- Mm Hmm.
- Meanwhile, your subconscious
and your fucking soul has been quietly
chipping away at your conscious
over the last, sounds
like 12 to 18 months,
helping you realize, I don't like this.
- Yeah.
- You're very fortunate.
You're at an extremely young age, for that
to become something that you're aware of,
then you follow it up with such
a thoughtful fucking question.
I'm proud of you, bro.
That was such a great question.
- Thank you.
- Unfortunately, people go from grades,
A, B, C, D, E, F to, you know, diploma
to salary, starting point,
to promotion and title.
And like everybody just
stays in this fucking game.
And to your point, everybody
judges themselves tangibly.
How many followers do I have?
How many, what grades did I, how many,
how much money do I make?
What car do I have versus the--
like and it all fucking sucks.
Meanwhile, if you judged yourself of like,
is today good, is this
week good, is this month?
Because today could be bad.
When people get caught on the way I think
about the world is they decide one day.
Sometimes I go three weeks
and it's not phenomenal,
but in the net of a
year, of a half a decade,
it is phenomenal.
So people over-judge the micro,
under-judge the macro,
but need to judge it
in the framework of
happiness and fulfillment.
Not outside affirmation.
- Gotcha.
I don't do Tea with Gary
Vee for the followers,
or the views or the things that nature.
I do it 'cause it feels
nice to help people.
I'm pumped, what Tomin and
Maria are feeling right now.
- Yeah.
- It's the easiest thing
to judge in the world,
brother, judge how you fucking feel.
- Okay.
I feel like I already know the answer
to this question, but when you say that
and when you're thinking about what
you want to do, how you
want to spend your time,
how much of a percentage
does money take up?
Because when I leave
college, there's a part of me
that really wants to be independent, like.
- It ebbs and flows, it ebbs and flows.
You know, I think, you know,
money's never been a big one for me,
mainly because I had the
ability to live humbly.
- Gotcha.
- I mean, dude, I'm not a fan of money.
I don't know what else to say.
Like I'm good at making it,
which I don't underestimate the gift
that is moneymaking, but I'm not
into it as much as people may think,
you know, they hear things like I wanna
buy the Jets and they
associate that with money.
My relationship with
money is very strange.
I love the fact that they're, you know,
I like the ability to do--
I like the ability to recognize
that my talent mixed with hard work,
created some variable of that execution.
But like, I don't know, man, like,
I'm even mustering I'm even struggling
to get hyped on money right now,
to balance out this convo
because I'm being empathetic
and compassionate and
sympathetic to individuals
who aren't good at making it, need it,
are struggling, so I
don't want to be glib,
but it's not about how much you make,
it's about how much you spent.
Like if you get out of college
and you live with your four most ambitious
to be happy friends in a shitty fucking
neighborhood in a garbage apartment,
you know, very quickly you
just don't need that much.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know, like, I mean,
I mean, you know, so for me, you know,
for everybody it's different, but for me,
I take for granted my ability to make it,
thus I don't respect it
as much as other people.
I work hard, I'm proud of it, but like,
I want to be happy more than like,
but like, but it's a funny thing, right?
Cause it's a scoring mechanism.
Like, so for example, like when I'm like
on eBay last night for like five hours,
trying to figure out which sports cards
are under priced to buy, it is under
the context of like, I'm going to buy this
Kareem Abdul-Jabbar rookie card for 2,000,
it's going to be worth 4,000 in a year.
It's not about the $2,000 profit.
It's about the smarts of seeing it.
- Yeah.
- I like, that's what makes it fun for me.
- Okay.
Okay, I get that, so it's like,
it's less about the actual money
that you're making, but the way in which,
like you're using different tactics
and strategies and it's like you say
a lot of time, it is a game and--
- It's a game, you know, I love being
an entrepreneur, I don't
want to diss on money
or entrepreneurship or capitalism.
It's just the money part's not the part
that gets me going.
I don't like looking at my money
or having it or saying how much I have.
I don't give a shit about that.
I like the game of getting it through
something smart or something noble,
or something hardworking or betting
on something for 10
years and then, you know,
it's business, I like business.
Like a business, I like
the business of it.
- Gotcha, gotcha.
All right, Gary, that's all I had.
Thank you so much for having me.
- John you're a super,
super thoughtful kid.
Listen to me.
You judge yourself on how good it feels.
- Okay.
- You're going to have
a very difficult time
in one transition.
You were not this good
student and the system,
your parents, the school
system, they told you
you couldn't, you took that.
You put that chip on your shoulder
and you fuck it stuck it to them.
Even the way that you
delivered the sentence
of showing your parents,
you took the energy
of you can't and you said,
fuck you, I'll show you.
And that was your driver.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I like that because I have a very,
I'm a very chippy fucker.
(laughing)
However, what I had layered on that
was I was chippy, but I was willing
to play a game where
there was no obviousness
to me winning and then it
was a surprise at the end.
You went through a game where you know,
it was affirmation every 90 days.
- Yeah.
- I'm trying to figure out how to
story-tell this to you, so
that you get out of that,
because if you can convert
it to the energy of,
don't worry about what everybody's saying
along the way, you're just gonna be like,
ta-dar, look at me at 30, I'm happy
and I'm fruitful,
ta-dar, look at me at 40,
I'm happy and I'm
fruitful, ta-dar, you know?
So try to figure out how you can still
play that game, that
clearly works for you,
but don't need, and in fact, how do you
get comfortable with
it being the other way?
I actually seek out subconsciously,
people to not believe in me.
- Hmm.
- I don't want the affirmation.
I want to be the underdog.
I want to be, one of the things
that's going on with me
is this whole Gary Vee
thing is a problem for
me, because now, you know,
Resi sold for a lot of
money, Case was sold
for a lot of money, Empathy
sold for a lot of money.
Like people are starting to realize
I'm not a motivational speaker.
I'm a fucking business,
fucking juggernaut.
(laughing)
And the more they believe that,
the more everything I do now gets received
with that's going to work,
instead of what I want,
which is this is not going to work.
- Yeah, yeah.
I think that it's difficult just because,
you know, it's really good for me
to have that tangible like, A, A, A.
But it's also like, I
can show it to my parents
and I can stick it to them that way.
It's hard to stick it to your parents.
Not that that's the goal,
but when I'm just like,
okay, I'm happy, you know and I--
- That's where you're not seeing it.
- Yeah.
- Let me promise you the number one
sticking it to people move in the world,
is saying you're happy.
Cause 99% aren't.
- Yeah, gotcha.
- They may not react the same way
as an A, but I promise
you, when you go back
to your car and you drive
back to your friends
and you have a nice Sunday
afternoon with them,
when your mom or dad's in the shower,
thinking they're like, first,
they're gonna be happy.
Cause they love you, but if there's really
some friction there or like some
little chippiness, I
promise you right now,
the number one way to win
this whole fucking thing, bro.
I know unlimited
miserable-as-fuck millionaires,
unlimited, I know more miserable-as-fuck
millionaires than I know
fucking happy millionaires.
- Damn.
- And bro, damn is right.
Because if you can, actually, if people
actually understood what unhappiness was,
it doesn't matter.
You know, when you're doing fucking
unlimited fucking prescription drugs
in your fucking mansion, you're not
a happy fucking person.
When you're fucking drinking a bottle
of fucking alcohol every night,
to two o'clock in the morning
in your fucking Maserati,
you're not a fucking happy person.
People need to wake the fuck up.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You're not winning.
- 100%.
100%.
- Yes, bro, you can show the --
Promise you, happiness is exactly
how you chip it.
- I'm excited to.
- Good, I'm excited for
you, I really believe
in you, bro, I intuitively
really believe in you.
That's why I'm keeping you on here.
I think you can really do this,
but I want you to challenge yourself
to get more comfortable
with longterm gray,
versus short term black and white.
- Yeah. I think that's
really, really hard,
because I would kind of put out content
for my small business, like, also sending
like a bunch of emails out every night.
It's hard to balance my time between like,
building up a lot of content and putting
out good information,
writing a little blog
and posting on Instagram,
doing all these things
that it's really hard to see
the return on investment.
You know?
- All things that are great are hard.
- Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it's just tough because like--
- Everything great is tough.
- Yeah.
- Anybody wants a 1% life and nobody wants
to put in the 1% work
ethic and mental strength
and patience required to get there.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I watch the world and everyone's like,
I want, I'm like, that's nice.
Everybody wants, 7.7 billion people want.
- Hmm mm, it's just so difficult because,
again in school and like, again,
I don't want to be like a victim here
and be like, school ruined
me or whatever it is.
But it really is a truth that--
- Bro, school didn't ruin you.
You ruin yourself if you believe that.
Cause you chose that was the outlet
to stick it to people.
I chose a different outlet.
- Yeah.
- I didn't double down on
school and apply myself.
I said, oh, you think I'm shit?
Watch this, I'm going
to completely check out,
get F's my whole life, hone my skill
on something I love and then be a fucking
savant, in your fucking mouth.
And now they fucking want to put statues
in my fucking high school of me.
A kid that they wanted to
kick the fuck out of there.
- I mean, how did you even deal
with something like that,
like having so many people--
- I enjoy when people think I s--
I love my haters on social media.
- Yeah I mean, you do talk
about that all the time
about it.
- It's the truth.
I mean, I don't know if people think
I'm out here for show, I fucking love it.
Let me get this straight.
You took the time to watch my video.
I don't even know who you are.
I don't know who you are, I have no time
to figure that out, I'm here to like
bring love, not hate.
You decided to obsess over what I'm doing.
And then you decided to leave negativity
and you're trying to bring me into
negativity loves company,
misery loves company.
Like you, I love it because it
adds a chip to my shoulder, I'm like,
I'm going to fucking
stick it to your face.
Karma, man, I feel so much sympathy
and compassion for you.
I feel so bad that you live a life
that behind a keyboard
and an anonymous name,
often with a private account, you decided
to spit hate, my God, you must be
in a very bad place, I love you.
I'm so sorry that you're living this life.
And I'm sorry that my light of positivity
and optimism and happiness is something
that you're so subconsciously jealous of,
that you need to try to drag it down
to even make it palpable.
- Yeah, it's all balancing
that grizzly bear,
with that cuddly teddy bear inside of you.
- Yeah. I like that.
I like that, I like that
analogy, I have that.
I'm a fucking assassin,
I will kill everyone.
Calm down, I love everybody.
And I have that, I have
that, I have nothing
but love, unlimited,
always give trust first.
Nothing has to be earned with me.
Who the fuck am I?
I love you, I love you, I love you.
You want to go into a dark place with me?
I'm ready to fucking
throw it out, fuck you.
- Yeah.
- You know?
And I've totally found that I promoted
one of my TikTok videos
that I post on Instagram.
I promoted, 'cause I felt like people
really like those videos
and the only comments
I got were people like, oh, like no one
can understand what you're saying.
Or like, this doesn't make sense, like,
your Facebook, like, this information,
like it's not good and here's why,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
And like, those were
the only comments on it.
- Dude, that sounds like
a successful day for me.
(laughing)
- Thanks.
- I mean it bro,
people see me now, everything I did
in the wine world with, you should of seen
my YouTube videos at first,
the entire wine industry
thought it was stupid.
and I had lost my mind.
Social media, it's a fad.
You've got this big wine business,
what are you fucking
around with Twitter for.
(siren blares)
- Bro, do you know how much,
how many whispers behind my back,
two years ago all my friends were making
about this obsession with sports cards
and it's so stupid and
it's a waste of my time.
That market has outperformed
the stock market
and the real estate market substantially.
- Yeah.
- I like the booze, I live
for the fucking booze.
I am devastated for my haters,
if they actually knew, if they actually
knew that their hate was my fuel,
they'd be, if they knew the chemicals
running through my body,
they'd be devastated.
- Absolutely.
- Devastated.
They'd be devastated by
knowing how much love
I have for them,
compassion, deep sympathy,
empathy, deep slash complete need
for their hisses and
boos because it fuels me
to fucking stick it to them at scale.
They would be crushed crushed, Jon.
- I love it.
- I love you, talk to you bro.
- See you later Gary.
- See ya.
Let's wrap this up.
Today's the one year
anniversary of Wine Text.
By the way that was fire,
let's get that clipped up.
Today, we have our one
year anniversary wine.
It is pretty remarkable.
It is one of the best
wines we've ever offered.
It's a 97 out of 100 point scored wine,
from Europe, that we are going to sell
for under $20 a bottle.
Literally, literally every single person
that's watching right now,
that literally every single person
that's watching right now that buys wine
in any shape or form,
should absolutely sign up
and pick up 12 of today's.
Please share winetext.com to every single
person you know with wine today.
Is the day, yep, under $20 a bottle.
Yup, under 20, today's gonna be wild.
That was a hard transition, Dustin,
from that emotional monster to like,
hey, we interrupt this program for
a Wine Text commercial.
- (laughing) Yep.
- but Dustin, you need
to buy a bottle today.
- Alrighty.
- Yup, re-activated, 'cause I'm sure
you're unsubscribed, 'cause you're a jerk.
(laughing)
No you're not a jerk,
because do not sign up
for Wine Text if you don't buy wine.
'cause it costs money to send a text, but.
Good show, that was a good one at the end.
There was some real deep shit there.
- Yeah.
- We are not back tomorrow because now
I have an issue, so we'll figure it out.
We'll let everybody know on social.
When we're back, hope
you enjoyed today's show.
- Word, can you also do the thing
that Sid asked for at the end?
You know, how he used to
deal with Ask Gary Vee,
you know, insure the podcast or whatever.
- What's that?
- Remember how you, at the end of like,
kind of likes as a
wrap-up on Ask Gary Vee,
of like what the episode was.
- Oh, on this episode?
Got it.
- Yeah.
- Is this for the podcast?
- I think and I'm going
to find out about that.
I didn't, I saw your tweet, you know,
the problems with the
audio levels and all that.
- Oh yeah, yeah.
I don't know if you saw it, okay.
On this episode of Tea with Gary Vee,
we talked to a 14 year
old starting a business,
a 54 year old, who's
going to switch it back up
and we get really deep
into the relationship
with haters and how to measure the gray,
instead of the short term black and white.
Good?
- Perfect.
- Awesome.
All right, everybody have a great day.
Hit me up on Twitter.
Wine Texts, I'm telling
you, big one today.